the emperor penguin is technically a
bird although one that makes his home in
the sea so if you're wondering what he's
doing up here on the ice well that's
part of our story that's a clip from the
oscar-winning 2005 documentary march of
the Penguins the film brought worldwide
attention to the extraordinary migration
these unique Birds make across
Antarctica each year showcasing the
vastness of the bird species exactly 100
years ago the US government passed a
groundbreaking law to protect migratory
birds that fly across the Atlantic to
mark that anniversary National
Geographic magazine helped to declare
2018 the year of the bird and it kicked
off the observance with an essay from
acclaimed author Jonathan Franzen who is
also a bird lover and a conservationist
in the middle of the country's biggest
metropolis is an urban oasis for bird
lovers even on a chilly late winter
morning some visiting relatives came
with binoculars we went out into the
park it was a similar experience 18
years ago that changed author Jonathan
Franzen's life forever they're peering
into this tree and there's this
incredible brightly colored little
Warbler sitting in this tree that I had
passed literally 500 times and the
scales had fallen from my eyes there was
this other world it was like being
introduced to sex in the two decades
since Franzen has traveled to see as
many of the world's nearly 10,000 bird
species as possible I've actually burned
it on all seven continents which has
been the best there's a bad kind of
birder who only cares about increasing
the length of his or her list of birds
seen here that kind of burner I have a
little bit of that but there's another
part of me that I think is a good burner
which is this is this is a way to have
an experience do you need vast amounts
of patience we met up with Franzen at
his home in Santa Cruz California it
wasn't long before Franzen found a
songbird that is a
chestnuts infect chickadee they're
related to the black kept you have in
New York that with that beautiful
chestnut back it's not as easy as it
looks
that's tricky again look at the bird
bring the binoculars up try to get a
little landmark you have to sort of lead
them a little bit but it's worth the
wait
yes that is the Townsend's Warbler now
right out in the open right there right
there oh you ought to be able to see
that Alex there right there we go here
we go oh another spectacular bird oh so
spectacular oh look at the colors yeah
that's a male Thompson's Warbler
that's a good one in his January essay
why birds matter and are worth
protecting
Franzen compares birds to humans writing
they build intricate homes and raise
families in them they take long winter
vacations in warm places cockatoos are
shrewd thinkers solving puzzles that
would challenge a chimpanzee and crows
like to play we live on an
extraordinarily weird and wonderful
planet yes yes birds show us how weird
the planet is and a lot of ways to to
the extent that there is still a natural
world the birds are the best ambassador
is for it because you can't go anywhere
on this planet without running into
birds you can be 90 miles inland and
Antarctica and there are the emperor
penguins you can be in the most bleak
South Pacific Ocean and there are the
albatrosses there seagulls nesting in
the desert I've seen great birds outside
my window in the Upper East Side in
Manhattan they're everywhere and always
not really caring very much about us
they're just being themselves but that
doesn't mean that humans aren't affected
by birds
Franzen remembers one experience in East
India when he was approached by two
great hornbills they flew in and it
sounded like some meteorological event
their wings are so huge it's as yes
woof-woof as they come in and as I
watched them climb around in this tree
they were eating fruit and
I became aware that somebody was
shouting and I realized I'm shouting
that is spontaneous joy that I am
omitting the joy is contagious as when
we came upon a pair of owls
we are always sleeping as far as I can
tell oh my god this is so awesome
this is the best Valentine's day ever
did everyone hear that Alex just said
best Valentine's date ever I mean what's
better hasn't seen two owls in a tree
there are some birds that are just
everybody wants to see them but they
really certainly don't disappoint do
they okay they're gonna be there for a
while so I want you to look at the
folder talk with that beautiful red
chest I have the white stripes and the
tail mmm are you on it look at the thing
and then bring the binoculars up yep
yeah it's so great being able to really
see them oh I see the stripes it's
moments like this that made Jonathan
Franzen fall in love with birds and
because I had fallen in love with him I
wanted to help them birds may have the
gift of flight yet Franzen points out
they are unable to master their own
environments humans are responsible for
the climate changing too quickly for
birds to adapt and Franzen wonders if
birds are valued enough for us to make
the effort to protect them part of my
mission has become to try to remind
people that there are other things to
think about if you care about nature
than just climate change climate change
often feels abstract exactly it feels
like something that will eventually
possibly happen and it sounds like your
interest in birds and conservationism
has to do with the here and now that's
exactly right
this month National Geographic is
highlighting how birds are able to
migrate thousands of miles every year
and how a changing landscape is making
it harder for them the contrast that is
interesting to me is between a kind of
fire and brimstone Christianity you are
damned unless you change your ways which
is kind of the climate conversation and
then on the other hand you have this
older Catholic particularly Franciscan
from Saint Francis who was all about hey
birds I love the birds I'm gonna write
to the Emperor and ask him to put grain
out in the fields on Christmas Day to
feed my friends the larks mm-hmm his
approach to the world was love love love
love love and I think for meaningful
action of any kind love is a much better
motivator than fear of damnation